vamos a hablar ahora de economía aquí en
france24 y estamos para eso con danger
hablando que nos va a contar lo más
importante en esta materia ni la
bienvenida de nuevo varias empresas de
eeuu dijeron estar dispuestas a pagar
más impuestos o la liliana pues
comencemos por decir que el presidente
joe biden quiere financiar un millonario
plan de infraestructura subiendo el
impuesto de renta corporativo del 21 al
28 por ciento el departamento del tesoro
dijo en un informe de 19 páginas que con
esto se recaudarían unos 25 billones de
dólares en 15 años
y un estudio independiente publicado la
semana pasada encontró que al menos 55
de nuestras corporaciones más grandes
utilizaron diversas estrategias para
pagar cero impuestos federales sobre la
renta en 2020 simplemente no es justo no
es justo para el resto de los
contribuyentes estadounidenses
intentaremos acabar con esto
liliana estas propuestas por lo general
no les gustan a las empresas sin embargo
varias de ellas ya dijeron estar
dispuestas a asumirlo amazon por ejemplo
lo hizo el martes y se han venido
sumando públicamente otras como
blackrock que es el mayor fondo de
inversión del mundo jaypee morgan el
mayor banco de este país la firma de
transporte el leaf y la desarrolladora
de plataformas
salesforce.com árida y renunció la
ministra de trabajo de chile bueno es
maría josé zaldívar quien estaba en el
cargo desde octubre de 2019 y según la
prensa local su intención de renunciar
venía de varios meses atrás el
presidente sebastián piñera nombró en su
reemplazo al diputado oficialista
patricio melero su tarea a liliana no
será sencilla tratar de liderar una
reforma de pensiones que es una de las
principales exigencias del movimiento
social que estalló en octubre de 2019
esta reforma por ahora está estancada en
el congreso lo que sí se aprobó en el
último año fueron dos retiros
anticipados cada uno del 10% en chile-
los fondos privados de pensiones de
reciben
ahorros de unas 11 millones de personas
y entregó 22 aeropuertos en concesión
por 30 años el gobierno recaudó unos 600
millones de dólares en las subastas
sobre los aeropuertos que representan el
11 por ciento del tráfico aéreo del país
las ganadoras fueron la francesa vinci
que se quedó con siete terminales y la
brasileña companhia de participaciones
en concesiones que obtuvo 15 estas
empresas no sólo pagarán por las
concesiones sino que también se
comprometieron a invertir unos mil
millones de dólares en los próximos años
esta es la primera de una serie de
concesiones con las que el gobierno
espera atraer inversiones por 1.800
millones de dólares en lo que ha
denominado el infra week estas incluyen
una línea de ferrocarril y cinco
terminales portuarios
daniela bueno y ahora hablemos de la
escasez de sobres de salsa de tomate en
eeuu no hay que el sap en el país no
señora pues la pandemia hizo que se
disparara la demanda debido a que no es
lo mismo a liliana que los clientes de
un restaurante consuman salsa de tomate
de dispensador a que lo hagan en sobres
y a domicilio
craft james company que posee casi el
70% de este mercado tuvo que aumentar en
un 25% su capacidad de producción con
eso va a llegar a 12 mil millones de
sobres por año una firma de análisis
cree que desde ya hay que pensar en
nuevas estrategias para afrontar esa
situación
el operador tiene que empezar a
preguntar a sus clientes si quieren
salsa de tomate así es así
cuánta quieren y así gestionar un poco
mejor el desperdicio y en última
instancia algunos avanzarán hacia un
modelo en el que cobren por ella y los
consumidores realmente no quieren gastar
más ya están pagando lo suficiente por
la comida que están recibiendo la mala
noticia la línea es que según el diario
the wall street journal los precios se
han disparado en un 13% y es muy posible
que se queden así por un buen tiempo
también y cuéntenos cómo están los
indicadores de la jornada sin liliana la
bolsa de nueva york que cerró mixta pero
con un nuevo recorte en el índice
standard and poor's que mide el
comportamiento de las 500 empresas más
grandes de eeuu en europa la bolsa de
parís está muy cerca de superar su
récord histórico logrado en junio de
2007 y en américa latina hubo cierres a
la baja en méxico y en argentina y
finalizamos con la cifra del día son 535
millones de dólares que registro de
superávit comercial en marzo chile que
es el mayor productor de cobre del mundo
esto significa que fue más lo que
exportó que lo que importó en este mes
gracias al fuerte repunte que ha tenido
este mineral daniela por la información
de economía y usted y gracias continúen
con más 24 puntos cuando vemos más
adelante
[Música]